et didier guillaume le président du
groupe socialiste au sénat est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir soi et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez vous
donc de public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse et dailymotion
la crise de l'élevage s'invite au coeur
de l'été nous l'évoquerons dans un
instant avec perrine tarneaud alors que
françois hollande annonce un plan
d'urgence et que stéphane le foll
finalement s'est rendu sans attendre en
normandie mais des réformes en
profondeur s'impose pour sortir les
éleveurs on les entend d'une situation
devenue intenable un dossier que vous
connaissez bien didier guillaume
d'ailleurs votre nom avait circulé un
pour le ministère de l'agriculture
verrait l'homonymie avec l'ancien
ministre on parlera également de 2017 au
cours de cette émission comment françois
hollande euros de son discours de près
candidat malgré une impopularité record
et même structure elle nous en parlerons
à la fin de l'émission avec katell
prigent alors que vous partagez au moins
un trait de caractère avec le chef de
l'état c'est à dire l'optimisme
ah oui puisque vous vous dites
optimistes sur la réussite du
quinquennat
je le pense je le pense parce que bien
sûr on veut tout le temps aller vite et
on se dit que le quinquennat aujourd'hui
il est fini on voudrait projeter les
élections présidentielles de 2017
aujourd'hui en juillet 2015 mais un
quinquennat dure cinq ans et aujourd'hui
les premières réformes ont été mises en
place jamais jamais un président n'a
autant réformes et que celui ci c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs un peu ça le
problème parce que les français ont du
mal à suivre
jamais autant mesures de fond était
prise dans une crise sans précédent la
guerre le terrorisme
la situation en europe et où il faut
repenser les fondamentaux de nos
équilibres budgétaires
il faut une gestion rigoureuse la dette
a filé des déficits ont filé dernier
quinquennat on peut nous dire j'étais à
cause de la crise 2008 va la crise elle
est toujours là et l'action du chef de
l'état français clairement oui le h est
bon on en parlera tout à l'heure vous
nous dire est que donc françois hollande
plus que jamais et le candidat qui
s'impose et qui est le candidat naturel
de la gauche en 2010 cet été guillaume
nous ramène tout à l'heure évidemment
quelle autre qualité s'impose à la tête
des sénateurs ps dans un sénat de droite
qui impose ses choix et sa vision au
carreau
bourg de la politique suivie par
l'exécutif mais le scénariste mal devant
brive et le sénat travaille et travaille
pas trop mal et l'opposition sénatoriale
arrive à se faire entendre
nous arrivons avant c'est d'ailleurs le
consensus que nous avons obtenus sur la
réforme territoriale en territoire c'est
le seul c'est déjà bien ça montre que
nous pouvons travailler avec la majorité
sénatoriale et je veux saluer le
président larcher d'avoir une courage
d'avancer dans cette direction
d'après ce que j'ai pu comprendre compte
l'avis du président du parti du parti du
principal parti d'opposition pourquoi
vous parlez de nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'il
y avait des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens nous y reviendront peut-être pour
l'aviculture tout à l'heure alors tout
le monde doit se dire avant que son beau
c'est beau ça lui est donc ce soir là
l'esprit de dialogue de gerland devront
absolument
il a il a été c'est un président qui
écoute qui a une liberté de ton et qui
est un président qui veut faire vivre
cette institution je veux saluer vous
allez peut-être encore le salut est plus
avant puisque vous aimez l'opposé à
nicolas sarkozy ni l'a dit que toutes
les réformes ne serait pas abrogée ça
aussi c'est une bonne chose ça sort de
sa bouche c'est évident nicolas sarkozy
n'est pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il est candidat pour
prendre sa revanche face à françois
hollande nicolas sarkozy ne comprend pas
qu'un autre que lui puisse être
président donc il abroge c'est monsieur
abrogatoire il veut tout abrogée et une
fille née il n'abroge sera rien parce
que j'espère que le peuple l'empêchera
de dette réduite alors jamais on n'a
autant réforme et l'affirmation et
pourra faire bondir certains dédié
guillaume est ce que c'est la fin
désormais des réformes avec le temps qui
va si vite vous l'avez rappelé le
quinquennat il reste deux ans mais non
non mais si on nous a annoncé le temps
de la redistribution info continuer à
réformer réformer sans cesse avait on
est un peu de tours de france c'est
comme le vélo 1
si on arrête de pédaler en se casse la
figure si le gouvernement arrête de
réformer il se cassera la figure il n'y
aura pas de possibilité d'une nouvelle
élection de françois hollande en 2017
de nombreuses réformes ont été faites
parlant du futur mari ben je peux vous
par des futures par exemple quand
personnel d'activité qui va être mise en
place très important une mesure sociale
évidente la loi bio dit
cité avec notamment la préparation de la
coke 21 ce que nous voulons mettre en
place nous c'est la social écologie
c'est à dire que l'écologie ne peut pas
être présentes uniquement par un parti
mais aujourd'hui l'enjeu planétaire veut
que chacun se souci d'écologie et le
président de la république était encore
ce matin au sommet des consciences avec
beaucoup de responsables politiques sous
l'animation de nicolas hulot il est
indispensable que cette prise de
conscience environnementale elle à
grande échelle
quelles sont les réformes pour vraiment
changer la vie quotidienne des français
et notamment résorber le chômage dans
notre pays et que la loi macron c'est
pas une grande réforme
ces images on parle des réformes à venir
elle est à venir celle-là michel
grossiord elle vient d'être votée il ya
quelques chants corses on avoue
l'agression et à venir il faut la mettre
en place quand on est là on l'a vu
macron 2 oui mais ça si on me demandait
mon avis mais je me demandais je vais
vous répondre je préférerais que de
l'eau macro 1 soit bien appliquée avant
qu'on essaye d'en aborder une autre
parce que je veux que nous réformions ne
réforme pas coude annonce en réformes à
coude objectifs politiques et les
objectifs politiques quels sont ils
c'est la réduction de la dette et des
déficits c'est la création d'emplois
c'est booster l'économie afin que
l'économie française fonctionne mieux et
c'est rendre le quotidien de nos
concitoyens sociales philosophie je vous
adresser directement à françois hollande
que vous défendez avec tout ça vous
serez d'accord mais vous répondait à
françois hollande qui a annoncé une loi
mais non pas du tout je vous êtes dans
les commentaires il a dit il peut y
avoir des mesures bas tout le monde a
compris cela en avoir discuté
peut-être mais nous verrons bien ce qui
se passera moi ce que je veux c'est
réussir l'instant présent l'instant
présent c'est en septembre 9 millions de
foyers fiscaux vont voir leurs impôts
baisser
c'est la première plus grandes baisses
fiscales de la vème république mais ça
fera évidemment pas les hausses
successives donnent toutes les années
passées
je suis de droite gauche confondues oui
mais je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
pour que l'on parle de ces hausses
oui 18 19 milliards d'euros sous le
quinquennat sahraouis 19 20 milliards
soul ben vous reconnaissez que ça n'a
pas été une bonne
option une bonne laissez moi finir mais
la grande différence entre ces deux
quinquennats
bien sûr qui a trop d'impôts en france
enfin on veut des services la grande
différence entre ces deux quinquennats
sexo nicolas sarkozy des impôts ont
augmenté le nombre de fonctionnaires a
baissé moins de pauses dans la justice -
deux policiers - deux gendarmes moins
une personne dans le renseignement
moins d'enseignants de fermetures de
classes c'est une réalité et nous
lorsque nous avons augmenté les impôts
par exemple nous sommes revenus sur la
fameuse loi tepa
nous sommes revenus sur le bouclier
fiscal nous avons augmenté l'impôt de
solidarité sur la sur la fortune nous
avons imposé le capital au même niveau
que le travail ah oui c était d aider
des médias pas d'autocritique et vaux
bien sûr je pense que nous avons trop
augmenter leurs impôts mais juste que je
vais vous dire ici c'est lorsque l'on
alors vous allez me dire parlez pas du
bilan c'est du passé
alors ce que l'on se retrouve en 2012
avec une augmentation de la dette de 600
milliards d'euros en un quinquennat vous
rendez compte que ces 600 milliards
d'euros ben il faut bien à essayer
d'ajuster quand même alors donc vous
l'avez rappelé il ya un instant didier
guillaume des compromis peuvent survenir
au sénat et comme par miracle sur la
réforme territoriale
norbert virage je crois que c'est par
conviction sauver les sénateurs sont des
femmes et des hommes de terrain
ils sont aperçus que nous pouvions
réformer de façon concrète
l'administration territoriale ce qui
s'est passé quand même il ya deux ans on
ne disait jamais nous n'arriverons nous
n'arriverions à diminuer le nombre de
régions là doivent avoir des élections
régionales peut-être apprendre en outre
à l'heure avec treize régions au lieu de
22 jamais nous n'arriverions à clarifier
les compétences s'est fait dans la loi
notre d'envoyer que c'est difficile nous
réformons c'est difficile
tous les conservatismes de droite comme
de gauche se rassemble pour dire non
c'est trop il n'empêche que nous devrons
avancer et pour la fin du quinquennat
moi je pense que nous avons besoin de
stabilité de continuité et d'efficacité
nous avons besoin de stabilité parce
qu'on ne change pas au milieu du gué une
stratégie on ne change pas la tactique
de l'équipe il faut avancer
même si nous avons eu des élections
difficiles et qu'il y en aurait d'autres
encore difficile
les régionales on est sûrs vous entendre
on peut être tout à l'heure même bien
sûr un peu de voir peut-être même
dramatique pour la dramatique le têt
nous verrons bien mais nous devons
avancer et nous devons contrôler mais
perdu leur avance j'ai dû commencer les
dramatiques voire suis sportif il faut
de la continuité aussi à graphique a été
ces mesures sont efficaces je voudrais
beau aborder un instant le débat
parlementaire parce que il prend des
allures de ping pong
vous l'avez noté évidemment entre le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale qui a le
dernier mot avec une grosse différence
quand même le ping pong est un jeu
rapide mais là ça freine tout vous lirez
vous le déplorez oui je partage ce que
vous dite je partage ce point je pense
que nous légiférons trop lentement
beaucoup trop lentement à l'heure de
l'instantanéité des faits c'est rare
d'entendre à part le mondial c'est le
discours de l'exécutif particulièrement
en france alors je vais vous le dire
qu'ils ont mais j'ai été rapporteur de
la loi agricole 1,8 en mai un an et demi
pour faire voter une loi quand sur le
mariage pour tous ont mis un nom sur la
loi macro mais plus de 1 non franchement
est la faute à qui mais c'est la faute à
tout le monde et surtout à nos
institutions c'est pour ça que je
j'aurai l'occasion de faire des
propositions d'ici la fin de l'année de
réformes institutionnelles exemple pour
essayer de finaliser la fin de l'année
comme essayer de et pistes de fluidifier
les pistes c'est peut-être que on n'est
pas 3 lecture par assemblée
lorsqu'il ya un texte franchement on
passe une première fois puis on passe
une deuxième fois il asséné garde ça
n'en finit pas alors il s'agit pas de
réduire le débat parlementaire
mais la première lecture doit être celle
où tout tout est sur la table
les amendements où on fait de la
confrontation politique en donne des
orientations différentes s'il le faut et
puis après il faut aller plus fort a pas
continuer on passa mais votre
gouvernement l'on s'y arrête de vous
proposer des textes avec des centaines
d'articles félicité de la loi mâcon il
ya un instant franchement oui mais nous
savons bien sûr que le gouvernement et
la 7' rétro du laos il est alors
entendez le bruit des arguments à tort
de vouloir nous faire trop d'accord avec
des textes trop important mais regardez
ce qui se passe c'est que le parlement
l'assemblée comme le sénat rajoute 50 60
cents 200 articles vous voulez limiter
ça aussi non pas du tout non non ce
serait le droit on peut pas dire il peut
pas y avoir plus de temps d'articles moi
je souhaite qu'il y ait
vous les lois et non de lecture et loi
moins bavarde des lois plus courte et
plus forte et des lois qui soit augmenté
plus rapidement en attendre à l'aventuré
j'ai sucé quand ils voient l'annonçons
conseil des ministres d'une proposition
de loi ou d'une loi et d'un projet de
loi pardon mais ça ne crois que ça va
c'est le gouvernement il joue de l'effet
d'annoncé
vous savez ça il joue le nom c'est le
nom à lui arrive ce sont les
institutions
michel grossiord et on doit annoncer en
conseil des ministres le projet de loi
il est annoncé et après la loi est
promulguée deux ans après ce n'est plus
possible et non celle ci alors nous
allons maintenant donc évoqué la fronde
des éleveurs mobilisés en normandie
notamment contre une crise sans
précédent et qui menace nous dit-on
officiellement une exploitation sur dix
aujourd'hui dans notre pays les secteurs
du lait de la vache de la viande bovine
et du port sont frappées de deux points
fait dans l'urne de pointe de plein
fouet depuis depuis des mois maintenant
mais dans l'urgence alors que les
actions se sont donc multipliées un plan
sera présenté ce mercredi en conseil des
ministres et donc stéphane le foll a
précipité son déplacement nathalie
gloire trop de l'agriculture a changé
d'avis aujourd'hui il décide de se
rendre à caen pour apaiser des tensions
il me semble logique à la fois par
respect pour les éleveurs du calvados et
de la normandie que je connais je suis
déjà venu et en même temps parce que
maintenant on a un certain nombre de
dispositions de répondre à la demande
qui avait été faite il ya quelques jours
de venir rencontrer les éleveurs sa
venue c'était l'une des conditions
imposées par les éleveurs pour la levée
du blocage des routes
il a enfin cédé sa montre que la
exactions qu'on a menée
ici au mont saint-michel paye et aide
ceux qui ont été à l'initiative de deux
ans maintenant aujourd'hui
attendons de voir ce qui va proposer
mais nous croyons pas au miracle
on est là pour un changement profond de
l'agriculture on est rendu au bout à
l'obsolescence totale de notre modèle
donc aujourd'hui il faut que les choses
changent
face à cette situation le rythme s'est
accéléré toute la journée
ce matin c'est françois hollande qui
reprend la main et monte au créneau
il donne le ton de la journée demain le
conseil des ministres prendra des
décisions
j'ai demandé qu'au delà de la question
de la distribution des prix il puisse y
avoir un plan d'urgence pour les
éleveurs français et pour les pauvres
gens de l'est ce sera donc annoncer
demain
pas question que la situation sont venus
davantage une réunion a donc été
organisée au pied levé ce matin à
matignon sur les filières d'élevage
le ministre par d'une dizaine de
propositions contenues dans son plan
d'urgence et évoque notamment la piste
de l'allègement de l'endettement des
éleveurs en attendant le plan d'urgence
qui sera dévoilé demain à la sortie du
conseil des ministres
le médiateur doit remettre son rapport
ce soir à stéphane le foll voilà donc
toutes les questions agricoles que vous
connaissez bien je disais tout à l'heure
un didier guillaume sans homonymie
possible avec huit ministres de
l'agriculture les questions de perrine
tarneaud michel sordi déjà sur la visite
de stéphane le foll sur le terrain
aujourd'hui pourquoi il a tant tardé à
venir à la rencontre des éleveurs qu'il
appelait depuis ce week end à venir il
s'agit pas d' accélérer de tarder ou ne
pas tarder à les voir les agriculteurs
sans que le dossier n'est pas stabilisé
et sans avoir quelque chose à leur dire
dur débat il est venu il n'a rien
annoncé
donc nous continuons il fallait prendre
le temps est ce que le temps s'était
situation inconnue
on connaît la situation déjà sur b le
plan le temps là oui mais le plan va
être présenté demain matin en conseil
des ministres
c'est pas le ministre de la culture qui
allait le faire ce week-end tout seul je
voudrais aller qui s'est précipité sur
or si vous le permettez si vous le
permettez la situation est trop grave
pour parler de coup de sifflet ou de je
ne sais trop quoi
stéphane le foll est un grand ministre
l'agriculture il connaît très bien son
dossier il va sur le terrain
il a alerté les éleveurs au sénat il ya
très longtemps
il a mis en place les cellules de crise
depuis février il a réuni le 17 juin
cette fameuse réunion où des choses ont
été
annoncée mais l'accord du 17 juin qui
n'est pas appliquée c'est ça qui
postulait sur le terrain et ce qui pose
aussi problème c'est son silence ce
week-end d'ailleurs l'opposition de
droite s'est engouffrée dans ce silence
du maire par exemple ils dénoncent le
mépris
oui le de stéphane le foll mais je vais
vous dire moi bruno le maire agite les
stéphane le foll agit c'est ça la grande
différence quand on a été ministre de
l'agriculture qu'attend quand on a
soutenu la lm que la loi de
modernisation de l'économie qui est ou
dérégulé quand on a été d'accord pour la
fin des quotas laitiers et quand on
prône le libéralisme économique
alors on devrait se taire on va avoir la
décence de ne pas faire de la
récupération politique parce que je vais
vous dire moi
perrine tarneaud ce que je pense c'est
que la récupération politique et des
fins régional par les présidents de
conseiller les candidats ou pour à la
présidence de conseils régionaux il
n'est pas acceptable c'est lui qui est
la leur aujourd'hui des éleveurs ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de fautes de la droite et de
l'europe libérale qui a voulu
libéraliser l'économie l'agriculture la
lme c'est monsieur sarkozy monsieur
philo années monsieur et monsieur le
maire et la fin des quotas laitiers
c'est la droite tu désolé maintenant il
ya trois crises et ces trois crises il
faut les voir en une seule fois et la
crise agricole la crise industrielle et
la crise sociétale qui ont mené une
minute je veux bien salée sans la crise
agricole
elle est très importantes à régler les
agriculteurs les éleveurs sont dans une
situation catastrophique
on ne peut pas les laisser crever dans
leur coin sans les aider il faut qu'on
apprenne il faut qu'ils comprennent que
ce gouvernement ce ministre le chef de
l'état le premier ministre sont là pour
les aider
moi je ne dirai jamais la culture est
finie
notre modèle agricole n'est pas finie
notre modèle agricole il a de l'avenir
et les éleveurs il faut les aider tout
simplement avec des prix je vais vous
dire ce que je pense là dessus mais
c'est pas vous qui fixe les prix y
attendez attendez acheter une voiture
achetée une table vous acheter une
baguette de paris
vous négociez pas les prix quelle
profession dans notre pays vend en
dessous du prix de revient
bah c'est scandaleux c'est ce qu'on
apprend à qui donc
or les distributeurs je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire l'accord du 17 juin il
doit être
en application il faut que les
industriels alors comment les
transformateurs il voyait parce que
visiblement il n'est pas exactement
c'est là toute la question mais c'est là
toute la question
alors je voudrais préciser ce que c'est
que cet accord du 17 août une
augmentation progressive du pain à l'ail
et au kilo un gros entre 20 centimes
toutes les fois l'air voilà en gros pour
le port emmené à 2 centimes de ce qui
était fixé pour noël pour le 17 juin
donc ça va à peu près on est beaucoup
plus loin sur les bovins mais nous avons
deux problèmes disons le faux faut tout
mettre sur la table un l'embargo russe
dont je pense qu'il faut que nous en
parlions parce que l'embargo russe pause
et bruno le maire mais il faut qu'ils
agissent mais je vais je vais vous dire
il faut que les leçons de budo le maire
ça suffit et puis il a parlé avec sursis
hollande en parler avec les acteurs
européens et puis la grèce la grèce
une grande majorité des jeunes bovins
sont exportés en grèce c'est aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que nous qu'est ce que nous
disent les transformateurs 10 mai trou
on veut être payé et on sait pas si la
grèce sera solvable une des raisons pour
laquelle on a bien fait de pas
l'assortiment
donc il ya ce problème là à crier moi ce
que je veux dire c'est que je veux dire
aux agriculteurs
c'est que nous les aimons c'est que nous
voulons qu'ils s'en sortent et nous
allons tout faire pour qu'il s'en sorte
pendant gens respectaient l'accord et en
mettant les transformateurs et les
industriels devant leurs responsabilités
c'est les grandes surfaces achètent plus
cher les bovins ou les ports et si les
agriculteurs se font toujours serré la
gorge au risque d'être étouffée
ça veut dire qu'au milieu et des
circuits commerciaux qui dysfonctionne
et on ne peut pas l'accepter
ça c'est la crise agricole il ya la
crise industrielle alors juste pour
finir sur la crise agricole dans les
solutions franco-françaises est-ce qu'il
faut aussi prendre en charge une partie
de la dette des éleveurs un milliard de
dettes cumulées selon life demandé à
discuter
que je respecte profondément c'est pas
ça le sujet n'importe quoi non pas du
tout pas du tout enfin un milliard
pourquoi pas 2 pourquoi pas 5
je pense qu'il faut que vision des
choses simples il n'y aura pas un jeune
éleveur en dépôt de bilan zéro tout
jeune
bien sûr tout jeune qui est endetté et
qui a dépensé de l'argent qui a emprunté
pour son élevage
alors celui ci nous on est des priorités
a aucun jeune ne doit être laissé de
côté et l'objectif c'est d'éviter les
dépôts de bilan
il faudra prendre des mesures qui
coûteront cher mais je ne peux pas dire
autour de cette table avec vous quand
bien s'est il est généralement fermés
nouveau des bonnets déjà d énergie d un
jeu aérien je vous donne vous
m'interrogez je vous donne ma position
je ne veux pas la position de stéphane
le foll
je pense qu'il faut aider les
agriculteurs au niveau fiscal vote et
puis il faut interpeller les banques et
notamment la banque des aviculteurs qui
n'a pas voulu jouer le jeu et il faut
c'est ce qu'a fait stéphane le foll la
semaine dernière en royans credit
agricole en juin d'autres banques en dix
ans maintenant il faut que vous aidiez
les éleveurs qui sont endettés faut
reporter des échances faut tout faire
pour s'en sortir
ça s'est il faut régler il faut aussi
peut-être des mesures de simplification
parce qu'il est une avance qui a été
consenti sur la pac mais les formulaires
sont trop compliquées
le ministre a pris des positions pour
aller plus loin dans il ya la crise
industrielle
c'est pour ça que l'entrée en lice dans
le débat des manuels macron ce matin et
est indispensable parce que quand nous
parlons des industriels
ses pattes sont pas des entreprises
agricoles et il faut travailler au
niveau de l'économie
et puis évidemment au niveau européen il
sait que c'est ce qu'a fait stéphane le
foll depuis des mois et des mois en
travaillant avec dassier en solo ce
d'abord puis maintenant avec le nouveau
commissaire européen
phil hogan en disant il faut tu avances
et c'est c'est le travail qui est fait
avancer la réforme changer quoi il faut
arriver à faire de la régulation
il faut que l'europe non mais je vous
dirai clairement il faut que l'europe
acceptent de mettre de l'argent sur la
table pour faire du déstockage
on n'a pas de choix autrement on n'a pas
le choix moi je veux pas que les
éleveurs qui crève
donc il faut que j'en aurais eu l'argent
poteev encore lui
le président du sénat a raison de saisir
le président de la commission européenne
eh bien c'est ce que fait le chef de
l'état le premier ministre et le
ministre de l'agriculture mois si tout
le monde droite comme gauche se disait
nous allons nous en sortir nous allons
tous interpellés tous tirer dans la même
direction
ça ne me pose aucun problème aucun
problème qu'il faudrait que le
gouvernement français demande une
réunion 1 des mises la deadline y en a
une il y en a eu il ya une à une il n'y
a pas très longtemps la vaisselle
il va y avoir une réunion des ministres
européens simplement la fin des quotas
laitiers n'a pas été interprété de là
mais on nous avait dit à l'époque en est
même prêt à affronter
on a été séduit par ce qui s'est passé
en chine
mais cgt fapt lui-même était confiant
non non non je téléphone le foll a voté
les derniers fans le foll étaient
députés européens il a voté contre la
fin des quotas et stéphane deux fois les
agricultures il a dit attention
attention mais à de nouveaux marchés
oui notamment la chine mais ils
n'obtiendront s'est précipité sur la
chine
aujourd'hui la chine achète moins de
lait et il ya un vrai problème puis si
je peux me permettre la troisième grief
sociétal le patriotisme le patriotisme
français une belle valeurs de
patriotisme et moi j'appelle tous mes
concitoyens
toutes les françaises et des français
quoi acheter français à manger français
asensi une solution de long terme des
studios de court terme et de long terme
si systématiquement lorsqu'on achète cet
été des côtes des merguez des chip au
jeu pas quoi pour faire mais pour faire
des barbecues
si on va acheter une côte de veau une
côte de boeuf une côte de porc si on
achète des fruits pourquoi ne pas
acheter français
enfin c'est indispensable et le label
viande de france mais les éleveurs
effectivement il n'ya pas un étiquetage
suffisamment il est mise en place la
défense a été lancé au dernier salon de
l'aviculture par le ministre la fnsea et
les filières d'élevage s'est élancé ça
va être à mon avis remis un peu au goût
du jour la viande de france c'est
absolument culture est tous d'accord
pour acheter pour manger français marine
bien sûr avec vous à rio mais oui mais
regardez par exemple je vois madame
emmanuelle cosse qu'est la secrétaire
nationale d'europe ecologie-les verts
dit elle on produit de la viande en fait
que personne ne veut qu'on achète plus
et qu'on réserve à l'exportation relais
ce qu'elle dit tellement
voulez me faire dire des choses
aujourd'hui moi je regrette vraiment la
dépêche d'emmanuel cos je ne pense pas
que ce soit une bonne position pour
rappeler que la vérité soit une bonne
position pour occuper de jeu les verts
de montrer du doigt les agriculteurs de
montrer du doigt ceux qui entretiennent
le paysage ac est montré du doigt ceux
qui sont de vrais écologistes à ce qu'on
le veuille ou non ça a évolué en 20 ans
et aujourd'hui les agriculteurs sont de
vrais écolos c'est eux qui entraîne des
paysages les éleveurs sans les éleveurs
il y aurait des friches partout dans nos
mondes à menacer la qualité de ce qu'on
mange et je regrette elle se trompe
oui quel des nations modèle
productiviste et bien le modèle français
pour moi il n'est pas mort le modèle
agricole français il a de l'avenir
il faut faire des évolutions on voit
bien il y aurait pas cette crise si tout
si tout allait bien dans le meilleur des
mondes mais je crois que ce genre de
discours
ce genre de discours contribuer à ne pas
arranger la situation donc je regrette
qu emmanuel pallas énoncé ses propos et
je regrette à une révision de la grille
modèle productiviste à bout de souffle
qu'on sait pas à bout de souffle et jade
et j'appelle moi tout les français des
français à manger de la bonne viande cet
été il ya de la très bonne viande de la
traiterait malgré tout pour servir est
ce que les agriculteurs français ne sont
pas obligés condamnés à se regrouper
dans des unités de production plus
importante
non je pense que notre modèle agricole
français il faut le maintenir pas le
maintenir pour le maintenir comme au
19ème siècle c'est pas ça le sujet moi
je suis opposé aux fermes des
millevaches et sagot duvauroux des 5000
ou des 10000 ce que j'ai non mais moi je
préfère un éleveur avec 50 ou 100 vaches
que un éleveur avec millevaches
voilà et donc ce modèle là il faut
peut-être moderniser les choses il faut
peut-être qu'il est les regroupements
faut peut-être que voilà ce travail-là
sur le long terme
il doit avoir lieu et les agriculteurs
et les filières d'élevage sont en train
de faire ce travail
mais aujourd'hui la difficulté dans
laquelle nous sommes elle est double
c'est qu'il faut répond une crise
conjoncturelle d'urgence sans ça il peut
y avoir des centaines d'éleveurs sur le
carreau donc il faut répandre des
mesures d'urgence et en même temps et
les problèmes de fond suffira pas donc
il faut continuer continuer continuer
sans cesse à travailler sur le fond pour
sauver notre modèle agricole pour nous
faire entendre au niveau
européens et pour faire en sorte que
cette agriculture puisse se développer
dans le cadre de la concurrence
internationale
réguler mais il faut la réguler et ça me
fait d'ailleurs toujours rire tout soit
les libéraux qui demande une économie
événement au niveau européen il ya aussi
une directive qui pose problème c'est
celle sur les travailleurs détachés qui
explique que notamment les charges
sociales dans les entreprises agricoles
allemandes soient beaucoup moins élevées
que celles social c'est un problème
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement et le chef de l'état entend
annoncer qu'il fallait régler le
problème des travailleurs détachés
je pense que nous arriverons à le régler
mais je pense qu'il faut pas opposer les
allemands aux français oui bien sûr un
beau mais ça le modèle agricole
d'accord mais enfin si on regarde très
objectivement les choses les problèmes
de l'élevage ou du lait enfin de
l'élevage en général soit pour la viande
ou pour le lait c'est pas parce qu'elle
est des des coûts de travailleurs
détachés plus bas en allemagne et je
crois qu'il ya pas que ça mais nous
avons quand même un événement
oui moi j'ai eu une europe qui régule
une europe qui puisse redistribuées et
surtout une europe qui aident à
traverser les difficultés
voilà c'est ça l'europe que je veux et
le travail que mène le président de la
république auprès de monsieur juncker
je crois qu'il a vu d'ailleurs le
commissaire pierre moscovici
hier où hier ou aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il soit souvent non mais souvent pour
travailler est ce que fait le misery
culture avec le commissaire européen à
l'agriculture doit porter c'est la cure
savez si je pouvais dire une phrase de
conclusion l'heure elle est très grave
très grave
il en va de l'avenir de notre modèle de
notre pays est ce que nous voulons
encore avoir des agriculteurs des
éleveurs des femmes et des hommes qui
travaillent 7 jours sur 7 pour faire des
produits de grande qualité en france où
est-ce que tout va être acheté à
l'extérieur de façon industrielle
ben moi je veux soutenir les
agriculteurs français et acheter des
produits de très grande qualité en
circuit court suppôts cible ou en
circuit non mais de qualité la qualité
avant tout et les agriculteurs doivent
entendre mais je pense que le ministre a
dû leur dire
cet après midi je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est dit dans cette table ronde et puis
ce soir la réunion avec l'ensemble de la
fille des filières
les présidents nationaux et demain les
mesures on a des occasions dans le bon
sens avec un risque de propagation en
tous les cas un temps dans des actions
je vous auriez vous avez peur
non je n'enverrai notamment la canicule
on fait de la politique apaisée on fait
de la politique je n'ai pas qu'il ya
deux choses que je veux dire c'est que
la sécheresse pose de vrais problèmes
pour la nourriture des animaux notamment
pour la paille et on aura en aura on
aura un problème
et puis quand même je comprends la
désespérance je me suis je pense que
certains éleveurs se distanciant je n'ai
plus rien à perdre il faut penser aussi
que dans les petites surfaces ou dans
les moyennes surfaces on a les grandes
surfaces et aussi des français qui
travaillent les français qui sont à
temps partiel qui sont à peine au smig
et je pense qu'il faut pas opposer les
catégories les unes aux autres
moi j'appelle au calme les
revendications sont normales ils ont des
choses à dire sound amoureuse des
éleveurs opposant dame et j'ai vu les
images à la télévision où il y avait
dans la gazet dénoncé les méthodes bien
sûr m'intimider aller les fournisseurs
mais évidemment pris la lm avec les
marges arrières l'émargement c'est
totalement ça très bien merci beaucoup
perrine dernière si le propre travail et
katell prigent de l' agence france
presse qui nous rejoint maintenant et
qui avait qui nous ont évoqué la
situation politique du chef de l'état et
que l'on voit donc présent sur tous les
terrains en ce moment surtout les voulu
roche-sur-yon pas présent il serait s'il
est alors présent il est trop mais s'il
n'est pas ou dit mais où il est une
manière pour lui en tous les cas c'est
sûr d'occuper l'espace politique parce
qu'il ressemble à une pré-campagne pour
2010 est pourtant les choses semblent
mal engagées
vous allez pouvoir répondre mais d'abord
l'enquète de louis sybille 2017 c'est
bien l'horizon de françois hollande
reste une épine dans le pied est de
taille
l'emploi la courbe n'est toujours pas
inversée
c'était pourtant le cheval de bataille
du président
de quoi remettre en cause sa légitimité
de candidat naturel
certains demandent déjà des primaires
une opinion partagée par 65% des
sympathisants de gauche
il faut qu il sera légitime auprès du
peuple de gauche je ne vois que les
primaires
sinon le mécontentement global
s'exprimant à l'élection présidentielle
est en tout cas s'il n'est pas capable
de gagner du primaire choix pas plus
comment il peut imaginer gagner une ex
en présidentielle pour ses fidèles
françois hollande est le seul candidat
possible certains sont très confiants
pour les deux prochaines années
la question ce n'est pas de savoir si
chômage va commencer à baisser ou pas il
va baisser la question réelle est de
savoir pour nous la gauche nous
souhaitons en 2017 voir la droite
revenir au pouvoir et si nous ne
souhaitons pas alors parti au moment où
cette courbe du chômage va baisser
il va falloir que nous tirions tous dans
le même sens et nous disons tous bien la
même chose
la seule chose qui à dire c'est que mène
pas une politique sociale libérale c'est
que nous menons une politique qui
fonctionne et qui redresse le pays il
est là le message
sur le plan diplomatique françois
hollande a peaufiné sa posture de chef
international avec l'intervention
militaire au mali sa gestion des
attentats ou plus proche son engagement
pour maintenir la grèce dans l'europe
pas de quoi capitaliser des points au
niveau national il ya un seul élément
qui lui permettrait de regagner des
points c'est d'obtenir des résultats
significatifs c'est à dire massif et
durable dans le domaine de la lutte
contre le chômage
même si le président arrive à baisser le
chômage difficile de penser qu'il
inverse sera complètement la courbe
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir il ay 1
600 mille chômeurs de plus mais pour ses
proches il ne peut pas changer de cap
le pire serait d'avoir une politique en
essuie glaces fait s'interroger
perpétuellement de se regarder le
nombril désiré ce qu'on fait bien où est
ce qu'on fait pas bien quand on trace
une perspective on s'y tient
vous savez quand vous charrues et un
champ vous passez pas votre temps à
partir à droite et à gauche vous prenez
au début vous avez jusqu'au bout on y
est problème un récent sondage montre
que même si le chômage baisse de façon
significative
75 % des français ne souhaitent pas que
le président de la république se
représente
voilà qu'apple présent est avec nous
bonsoir capelle non add your mais alors
là encore est ce que vous êtes optimiste
sur françois hollande candidat malgré la
question du chômage comme épée trimestre
nous le disions tout à l'heure en début
d'émission il reste deux ans des
élections présidentielles auront lieu
dimanche prochain
je me serais un peu moins optimiste et
on n'est pas là on est en train de fixer
le cadre pour préparer la fin du
quinquennat
avant de penser à l'élection
présidentielle il faut penser aux
français et moi je veux nous pensions
aux français c'est ce que fait françois
hollande c'est ce que fait manuel valls
et le gouvernement et les parlementaires
socialistes qui les soutiennent c'est
quoi les français ils veulent du travail
de la sécurité et un logement mais c'est
ce que nous essayons de mettre en place
avec les diverses lois que nous avons
voté depuis 2012
il reste deux ans utilisons ces deux ans
pour continuer à réformer
l'élection de 2017 va pas non plus se
préparer à la veille de semaine avant
elle commence déjà ça commence déjà ce
crochet et préparer le 6 mai depuis le 6
mai 2012
oui donc justement les du quinquennat
fait que le lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle on électoral s'était
réjoui françois hollande a bien sûr les
françois hollande a été très clair il a
dit si le chômage continue à augmenter
je ne serai pas en mesure d'être
candidat je ne sais trop quoi dont tu as
terminé on verra bien le moment venu
moi je pense que françois hollande doit
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en 2017
c'est celui qui peut rassembler la
gauche pour rassembler les français
pour être élu parce que l'offre
politique elle est simple les français
nous disent on ne veut pas revivre 2012
mais vraisemblablement il y aura marine
le pen nicolas sarkozy et françois
hollande
donc ils veulent pas le revivre enfin le
choix ils devraient le choix il devra
être là qu'on le veuille ou non après on
peut dire on peut voter pour d'autres on
verra bien mais on risque de se
retrouver avec ses 3 votre seul argument
c'est 2
le vote contre l'asie le pen cocody ça
et on a entendu dans le sujet d'ailleurs
monsieur les abonnés à se dire le chu
carvounas dire je vous dis oh dire aux
français si vous votez pas pour nous
c'est un droit il ya une chose qui est
sûre
non mais vous avez entendu cet argument
et j'ai entendu alors qu'est ce que je
vais vous le prenez pas votre je vais
vous répondre je ne reprends pas tout à
fait encore mais je vais vous répondre
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour les gens de
gauche c'est le front national nicolas
sarkozy ou françois hollande s'il y
aller je vais vous donner ma position
après s'il ya des gens de gauche puisque
nous parler de cet argument oui et ils
disent nous ça ne nous intéresse pas bon
ben alors terminé on rentre à la maison
et puis on laissera à l'extrême droite
ça veut dire qu'on a perdu tout boussole
est toujours pas illogique moi ce que je
pense c'est que les mesures que nous
avons prises
les réformes que nous avons fait et
celles qui vont venir encore peuvent
permettre de relancer la machine
économique peuvent permettre de faire de
la redistribution et peuvent permettre
de faire la différence entre une
politique de droite une petite de gauche
parce que c'est bien de cela dont il
s'agit
quand nous allons arriver à l'élection
présidentielle si les choses se passent
comme je le souhaite
et bien il y aura des débats il y aura
des confrontations bilan contre milan
sondage roger contre je montre bien
pourtant françois hollande n'a pas la
cote
aujourd'hui on laisse dire y compris
celle et surtout chez les sympathisants
pour l'instant aujourd'hui à 50% des
électeurs de gauche qui souhaitent sa
candidature et 50 % qu'ils la souhaitent
pas bon ben on commence comme ça voilà
on est à 200 dans les deux ans qui
viennent nous allons faire ce ce travail
fera monter une stratégie de à aulas
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
l'objectif n'est pas de dire faut que
françois hollande soit élu pour être élu
pour être élu c'est pas nicolas sarkozy
qui tu as pu atteindre tous les matins
en disant je veux redevenir président de
la république lui il est une idée de la
france il a celle de la faire rayonner
enfin quand même quoi le 11 janvier et
ce qui s'est passé à bruxelles pour la
grèce quand j'ai entendu les trois
positions différentes en trois jours de
nicolas sarkozy je me dis
qu'heureusement heureusement que le chef
de l'état c'était françois hollande donc
l'un des arguments de campagne donc un
positionnement de françois hollande que
ça son idée de la france et des usa
son idée du
monde de l'europe et de la france elles
sont dites blanches sera t-elle lagos
qu'elle est contestée
la gorge du voyage même la fin du ps non
moi je pense que la vieille gauche que
la vieille politique
je voulais déjà dit je crois ici c'est
terminé c'est terminé
les vieux partis qui entre font leurs
trucs et puis en mai tel candidate c'est
fini tout cela les français n'en veulent
plus d'ailleurs quand je vais au bistro
bar café où l'apéro quand je rencontre
des amis quand je fais des dîners avec
des potes
qu'est ce qu'ils me disent mais mon
vieux tu a sacrément de morale de faire
de la politique parce que leur nous elle
nous fait gerber voilà ce que j'entends
et oui et donc à partir de là eh ben
nous ramenons ces gens là vers françois
hollande vers une idée de la france
pas des polémiques stériles pas je suis
dans l'opposition donc je suis content
mais nécessaire même si c'est bien la
france une france qui rayonne dans le
monde
je crois qu'il l'a montré qu' un poids
fort au niveau européen la france ne
s'est pas ballotté
le couple franco-allemand madame merkel
monsieur hollande on a vu qu'ils avaient
d'eux qu'ils avaient de la pêche et de
la pointe certains étant on a pas on
n'est pas allé là-bas à 15 on voit bien
la stature de chef de l'état voilà
l'étrange et juniors voilà 77% de mais
combien sur éthique du président a
assuré que les gens soient intéressés
sur la politique intérieure
je vous dis vous imaginez comme moi je
me place tous les matins vers mes
concitoyens mes voisins dans la drôme à
bourg de péage dans la commune ceux qui
sont au chômage
ceux qui ont peu de ceux qui ont peu de
revenus 10 mai la politique qui est
menée ne va pas mais aujourd'hui c'est
fini on rasera gratis c'est fini la
politique en cinq jours les gens ont
entendu mon ennemi c'est la finance et
se disent donc du coup on va prendre
l'argent aux riches pour donner aux
pauvres
mais c'est pas aussi simple que ça nous
ce que nous pensons qu'il faut que
l'économie redémarre que l'économie
fonctionne qui créent de l'emploi
c'est pas les socialistes ce sont les
chefs d'entreprise quelle échelle
entreprises peuvent créer de l'emploi
par les mesures prises par le chef de
l'état et le gouvernement le pacte de
responsabilité et c'est eux
il commence à porter ses fruits je le
vois tous les jours dans mon département
pour les petites entreprises et donc
c'est sur la durée il reste encore deux
ans et j'espère tu en fis le temps
j'espère que nous arriverons à avancer
mais pour ceux
il faudra aussi rassembler la gauche
ah oui vous reste quand on a une base
politique extrêmement étroites les
surveillants gauche quand on voit vous
ne rassemblez déjà pas pour les
régionales alors pour les régionales moi
je vais vous dire soit la gauche est
unie sur la gauche est anéantie
elle va être à dire parce que je n'en
sais rien bayer est désunie elle a donné
à deux tours dans une élection quand
même il ya deux tours dans une élection
moi j'appelle j'appelle mes amis
écologistes les communistes les partis
de gauche les leur a dit les radicaux et
cetera à se dire au moins dans deux
régions nord-pas-de-calais picardie
immense île de ré et provence alpes côte
d'azur à d'alliance attendait que l'on
gère depuis trois mandats ensemble que
l'on gère ensemble dont les uns et les
autres sont vice-présidents partagent le
même bilan font le même bon travail sur
les transports sur le sur l'aménagement
du territoire et caetera et pour des
raisons qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'élection régionale veulent partir de
façon indépendante
je pense que ce n'est pas responsable
mais moi je veux être unitaire pour deux
alors je leur dis si au premier tour
pour des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les régionales vous voulez vous
présenter assumant le fait d'ores et
déjà qu'il y aura un rassemblement de
ceux qui gouvernent en les régions
ensemble
enfin comment nos concitoyens dans la
région rhône alpes où ailleurs voit que
la gauche gère la région mais que aux
prochaines élections régionales ne
serait pas ensemble ça n'a aucun sens
donc j'appelle à l'unité pour
rassemblement
il est encore temps d'avancé et si ce
n'est pas possible pour le premier tour
alors assumant maintenant qu'au deuxième
tour
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont géré
les régions ensemble doivent continuer à
le faire on peut avoir
on peut avoir des divergences sur la
politique gouvernementale menée sur la
pause et de la position du chef de
l'état ou du gouvernement
mais de quoi s'agit-il l'élection
présidentielle sera après là c'est la
gestion ce gris région ce que vous
reproche justement europe ecologie les
verts notamment c'est de dire
rassemblons nous mais derrière nous
disons à chaque élection c'est la même
chose
ben si vous savez la politique sait les
rapports de force et la proportionnelle
on peut pas discuter quand un parti fait
20% un autre fait 10 c'est celui qui
fait 20% qui doit mener la liste après
lorsqu'il ya désaccord
il ya des accords de réciprocité enfin
pour les élections sénatoriales l'ailé
sénateur europe ecologie les verts qui
ont été élus ils ont été élus sur les
listes socialistes aux élections
législatives de 2012
la plupart des députés qui ont été élus
n'auraient pas été élu s'il y avait eu
des candidats socialistes en face d'eux
donc c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est pourquoi moi je milite pour la
social écologie pour le rassemblement de
toute la gauche car je crois qu'il faut
dépasser les appareils il faut dépasser
les trucs d'épicier de boutiquiers il
faut dépasser cela
quelle idée avant nous pour notre pays
pour la france la république l'écologie
le social l'économie on peut pas se
mettre d'accord bon sang de bonsoir là
dessus ben non 24 ans est difficile et
on a entendu marie noëlle lienemann
jusqu'au bout vous irez jusqu'au bout
marina vous aussi d'y arriver bien sûr
l'idée d'une primaire là pour re
légitimer légitime et françois hollande
est ce que ça vous paraît une bonne idée
non mais parce que c'est une option
ça ne peut pas être une option lorsqu'un
président de la république et sortants
s'il décide de se représenter
s'il est en situation si les principaux
responsables politiques autour de lui
veulent aller dans cette direction il
n'y a pas besoin de primaire la primaire
est une condition qu'ils aient par le bo
a mis la gomme et verbaux qui est posée
par marie noëlle lienemann et paul qui
est petit est d'accord ce qui est posée
parce qu'après monsieur montebourg
aimerait parce qu'ils ont été en
revenant lui il aimerait être candidat
qui ont été en rupture avec en a qui ont
été servis par la république quand même
qu'ils ont été servis servi parce que
monsieur montebourg ils se sont servis
mais non monsieur montebourg et madame
filippetti ont été servis par la
république vous rendez compte soit
ministre de l'économie du redressement
productif de la culture mais quand on
est membre d'un gouvernement
on doit dépasser sa petite personne on
ne s'appartient plus mais c'est la
france quand on parle ont quitté ce
gouverneur et aujourd'hui il réussit
grand livre savez chez moi on appelle ça
cracher dans la soupe
ma grand mère disait toujours faut avoir
la reconnaissance du ventre c'est bien
le mot serviront bien très bien choisie
alors quand le mot servirait donc bien
fait ils ont été choisis à un moment par
le chef de l'état et ses retours est
membre d'un gouvernement
voilà donc aujourd'hui un peu de retenue
c'est ce que j'appelle validera pas la
rentrée on attend mon mur montebourg
évidemment avec monsieur dauphin qui se
produiront à eux franchi 2
e ministre viré leur gouvernement oui
d'autres mais vous nous avez parlé de
l'hypothèse nicolas sarkozy pour vous et
certaines maintenant il ya aussi pour
amen alain juppé que bien passé d'après
les sondages et qui aurait d'ailleurs
une partie et les faveurs d'une partie
de l'électorat de gauche scrutera moi je
n'aime pas un spécialiste en en ump en
stratégie des républicains
oui voilà bon il me semble que les
choses se passeront récemment comme ça
mais ça n'appartiennent pas d'accord
prévient pense que le moment venu
les gens de gauche ou en défaveur pour
le candidat de gauche parce qu aura
quand même une différence emprunter la
gauche quand on présentera le bilan et
le programme
merci katell merci guillaume merci à
vous qu'on était à vous avons tous à
vous aussi qui nous suivait et prochain
rendez-vous de preuves par 3 sur public
sénat et ce sera le 8 septembre de très
bonne et agréable semaine à vous tous
d'ici là a très vite